vous voulez sous chacun des bureaux
seraient des prises aux branches et
locmariaquer et après en cuisine vous a
été caché à volonté comme vous le
souhaitez il est désormais ouvert du
lundi au vendredi le nouvel espace de
coworking de jouars-pontchartrain est et
inauguré ce mercredi 4 mai au total 500
mètres carrés aménagé dans un bâtiment
du xviiie siècle l'ancien relais de
poste c'est le coeur battant du
coworking c'est l'espace de convivialité
c'est la cuisine où tout le monde va
pouvoir venir évidemment se restaurer on
a pensé convivialité on a pensé des
espaces donc partagé pour la
convivialité pour le travail et aussi
des bureaux fermés parce qu'on se rend
bien compte qu'avec les colloques au
vide que des grands espaces ce n'est pas
forcément ce qui est demandé par tous
avec deux salles de réunion trois
plateaux de travail et huit bureaux
l'objectif de l'espace et de s'adapter à
tous que ce soit des télétravailleurs
savait qu étant en télétravail depuis le
début de la pandémie ça permet voilà un
petit peu de sortir de son de son
quotidien et puis d'avoir un certain
confort en termes d'installations c'est
vraiment un très beau bâtiment moi je le
connaissais pas du tout donc vraiment le
choix des matériaux de l'agencement etc
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment super ou
même des entrepreneurs à l'image de cet
homme j'ai tout à créer maintenant par
rapport à mon projet professionnel et
notamment faire du réseau
rencontrer des gens et donc
l'orientation écologie qui a été
présentée fera par monsieur le maire ça
forcément ça peut m'intéresser en vue de
construire cette nouvelle partie de ma
carrière penser en 2017 par la commune
il aura fallu patienter cinq ans avant
de donner une nouvelle vie à ce lieu
historique près de la mairie fréquenté
il fut un temps par le poète alfred de
musset nous avons rencontré de l'amiante
du plomb le coc vide des interruptions
de chantier bon en fait tout ce qu'on
peut cumuler comme comme problématique
mais finalement on a tenu bon on ouvre
et puis je pense que le résultat est à
la hauteur un coût total avoisinant les
2,5 millions d'euros pour les futurs
abeilles de la ruche les tarifs ne sont
pas encore définitifs les tout premiers
inscrits ont pu bénéficier d'une offre
spéciale le mois de mai était gratuit